[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy
esta vez el coronavirus no detuvo el
estallido social en colombia a pesar de
las prohibiciones dos ciudadanos
salieron masivamente a rechazar la
reforma tributaria del presidente iván
duque las movilizaciones que retomaron
el impulso de las de 2019 antes de la
pandemia fueron principalmente pacíficas
pero al margen se registraron algunos
disturbios el presidente joe biden
cumple 100 días en el poder y para
celebrarlo dio un mensaje a la nación
desde el congreso en el que resaltó sus
logros la gestión de la pandemia y el
regreso de eeuu como el líder en la
comunidad internacional fueron algunos
de ellos pero también reconoció los
retos que tiene como la crisis
migratoria el racismo estructural en la
policía y los controles al porte de
armas
y hollywood vivió una de las ceremonias
más extrañas de entrega de los premios
oscar en la historia del cine tras una
caída sin precedentes del 80 por ciento
de los ingresos en taquilla debido a la
pandemia les contamos por qué los
productores se mantienen optimistas
y comenzamos en colombia las
prohibiciones contra el coronavirus no
detuvieron a los colombianos que
salieron masivamente a las calles en
rechazo a la reforma tributaria del
presidente iván duque en cali la tercera
ciudad del país se registraron
disturbios mientras que en bogotá la
capital también hubo algunos incidentes
violentos incluido el intento de toma de
un canal local de noticias pero en
general el paro nacional fue pacífico el
gobierno ha dicho que no retirará el
proyecto de ley pero invito al diálogo a
todos los sectores la polémica reforma
busca rescatar la economía de los
estragos de la pandemia pero es
particularmente dura con la clase media
es la tercera reforma tributaria de iván
duque en tres años de gobierno con ella
busca recaudar 25 billones de pesos
cerca de 6 mil 800 millones de dólares
la llama la ley de solidaridad
sostenible
[Música]
que hay que ver que tenemos hoy es
seguir protegiendo a los más vulnerables
y protegiendo la estabilidad de las
finanzas públicas pero que lo hagamos
con un gran consenso que se construya en
el diálogo parlamentario donde busquemos
los aportes de todos donde encontremos
las mejores herramientas para tener
ingresos y proteger a los vulnerables
pero para hacerlo reduce el monto de
ingresos mínimos a partir del cual los
ciudadanos deben pagar impuestos por sus
ingresos así quienes en 2022 ganen más
de 2 millones 400 mil pesos al mes o 640
dólares deberán declarar renta y para
2023 quienes ganen más de un millón
setecientos mil pesos o 460 dólares
deberán pagar
hasta ahora sólo los ingresos desde
alrededor de 1000 dólares estaban
obligados a pagar en un país en el que
el salario mínimo es de 248 dólares el
proyecto de ley también plantea aplicar
un impuesto del 19 por ciento a la
tarifa de los servicios públicos para
los sectores más adinerados así como
algunos de los productos de la canasta
básica e incluso a los servicios
funerarios nos quieren cobrar impuestos
e iba por absolutamente todo le va a
poner libra y va a la canasta familiar a
los costos funerarios a la gasolina a
todo porque eso es lo que quiere el
gobierno que el pueblo colombiano no
salga marchar y la excusa es que hay
como vides que hay virus pero no hay
virus más grande que el mismo gobierno
colombiano además crea un impuesto
temporal a la riqueza para quienes
tengan grandes patrimonios o empleados
que ganen más de 2 mil 700 dólares si el
pueblo colombiano no lucha no
adelante y nos van a clavar una reforma
totalmente arbitraria que nos va a
llevar a aguantar hambre empobrecer más
el pueblo y es lo que no queremos el
paro nacional fue convocado el tiempo
que colombia pasa por el peor momento de
la pandemia de ccoo y 19 inició el mismo
día que el país registró su peor récord
de muertes y mientras rige un toque de
queda por la ocupación de las unidades
de cuidados intensivos que está casi al
límite
y allí mismo en colombia los
enfrentamientos en la frontera con
venezuela continúan el ministro de
defensa venezolano vladimir padrino
aseguró que ocho soldados de su país
murieron en choques con grupos armados
ilegales de la vecina colombia que se
cree son disidencias de la extinta
guerrilla de las farc más de cinco mil
venezolanos se han visto obligados a
huir después de que el ejército de
venezuela lanzó un operativo en el
estado de apure poniendo al límite la
capacidad de respuesta para acogerlos de
los municipios fronterizos colombianos
colombia ha acusado históricamente a
venezuela de ofrecer refugio a las
guerrillas
y sigamos en eeuu con la imagen de la
semana el presidente joe biden entregó
su primer discurso ante el congreso en
el marco de los 100 primeros días de su
gobierno por primera vez en la historia
lo acompañaron en el podio dos mujeres
la vicepresidenta kamala harris y la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi los dos
cargos de mayor rango en la unión
americana tras el mandatario
fue una noche de celebración aunque solo
asistieron alrededor de 200 personas
muchas menos de las 1000 que suelen ir a
este tipo de discursos presidenciales el
mandatario exaltó sus logros y comenzó
por el más evidente más de 200 millones
de dosis de la vacuna contra el cob y 19
aplicadas tras una pandemia que dejó a
eeuu como el país más afectado del mundo
sin embargo advirtió que aún hay trabajo
por hacer en un evidente llamado a los
escépticos de las vacunas que son uno
entre cada tres estadounidenses según
una encuesta de la agencia de noticias
ap
de ayer sexy y todos los que tengan más
de 16 años todos son elegibles para
recibir una vacuna ahora ahora mismo
vayan a vacunarse eeuu vayan a vacunarse
están disponibles
[Aplausos]
cuando julia el 20 de enero menos del 1%
de los adultos mayores estaban
completamente vacunados en contra del
cob y 19 100 días después 70% de los
mayores de 65 lo están están
completamente protegidos
las muertes de adultos mayores por kobe
19 disminuyeron un 80 por ciento desde
enero 80% gracias a todos ustedes y más
de la mitad de todos los adultos en eeuu
han recibido al menos una dosis
galanismo ansa
vayan también presentó un nuevo programa
económico por 1.8 billones de dólares
con el que busca atender las necesidades
de las familias explicó que quiere
garantizar el acceso a la salud y a la
educación universal y para lograrlo
prometió que aumentará los impuestos a
los más ricos y a las empresas
no voy a imponer ningún aumento de
impuestos a la gente que gane menos de
cuatrocientos mil dólares pero es hora
de que los empresarios de eeuu y el 1%
más rico de los eeuu empiecen a pagar su
parte justa marca bliss
muchas compañías evaden impuestos a
través de paraísos fiscales en suiza y
bermuda y en las islas cayman y se
benefician de los huecos en la ley y
deducciones por compañías offshore fuera
del país eso no está bien vamos a
reformar los impuestos empresariales
para que paguen una parte justa que
ayuden a pagar las inversiones públicas
de las cuales sus negocios también se
van a beneficiar
maxwell
el presidente también aprovechó su
primer discurso ante la nación para
pedirle a los republicanos en el
congreso que aprueben las reformas que
su partido ha impulsado son dos la
reforma migratoria un tema ampliamente
divisorio en el país en febrero bailén
presentó un plan para abrirle un camino
a la ciudadanía a los 11 millones de
indocumentados que se estima hay en el
país y la segunda es la reforma a la
policía que fue presentada tras el
asesinato de georg floyd y que propone
entre otras cosas prohibir las maniobras
de ahogamiento además urgió por mejorar
los controles para acceder a armas de
fuego
tenemos que unirnos para reconstruir la
confianza entre las fuerzas del orden y
las personas a las que sirven para
erradicar el racismo sistémico en
nuestro sistema de justicia penal y
promulgar una reforma judicial en nombre
de georg floyd que ya fue aprobada por
la cámara
finalmente bailan de estar con sus
logros en política internacional con el
regreso de eeuu al acuerdo de parís y
los nuevos diálogos con irán con miras a
restaurar el pacto nuclear celebró
además el retiro de las tropas de
afganistán y la competencia saludable
con china mientras que advirtió a rusia
que sus acciones tendrán consecuencias
lo he dicho a varios líderes mundiales y
eeuu no va a huir de sus compromisos
nuestros compromisos con los derechos
humanos las libertades fundamentales y
nuestras alianzas
ningún presidente estadounidense se va a
quedar callado cuando se violan
flagrantemente los derechos humanos
el presidente debe representar lo que
nuestro país representa eeuu es una idea
la más única en el mundo todos somos
creados iguales
o dos y por los premios oscar fueron la
cereza del pastel de uno de los años más
inusuales en la historia del cine muchas
de las películas nominadas fueron vistas
por primera vez en la pantalla chica a
través de plataformas de streaming la
ganadora a mejor película no mad land es
la de menor recaudación de taquilla en
la historia en recibir este galardón
eeuu regresa poco a poco a la normalidad
y las cadenas de cine no pueden esperar
con la esperanza de recuperarse de las
millonarias pérdidas ocasionadas por los
cierres para contener la propagación del
cobi 19
no mad land es la película con menores
ingresos en ganar el oscar a mejor
película mientras hollywood apuesta por
una recuperación de la taquilla para los
cines estadounidenses en el último año
la mayoría de los teatros permanecieron
cerrados debidos a la pandemia de kobe
19 lo que llevó a los estadios a
retrasar sus grandes películas haciendo
que los ingresos cayeran a poco más de
dos mil millones de dólares una caída
del 80%
los cines han luchado por permanecer a
flote y software la cadena álamo
drafthouse ya se declaró en bancarrota y
los cines arclight anunciaron que no van
a abrir todas sus 300 pantallas creo que
eso es sólo la punta del iceberg
de strippers y ese es el 3% creo que
vamos a ver fácilmente el 10 por ciento
e incluso del 20 al 25 por ciento caer
durante el próximo año los cines ella en
sí los más grandes del mundo perdieron
4600 millones de dólares en 2020 y
cinemark perdió 618 millones la pandemia
también ha cambiado el modelo de
distribución
warner brothers optó por estrenar todas
sus películas nights biomax al mismo
tiempo que en los cines pero hollywood
se mantiene optimista no puede
reproducir la experiencia de ver una
película en el cine con otras personas
que no conoces y como productor quiero
ver mis historias en estos lugares no
quiero que simplemente sean transmitidas
en casa no es lo mismo y creo que si el
coi 19 nos ha enseñado algo es la
importancia de la comunidad y de
experimentar cosas juntos la mitad de
los tienes estadounidenses
abrieron los teatros esperan un verano
cerca a la normalidad
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa síganme en la dirección
que ven en sus pantallas cuídense mucho
el coronavirus y sigan viendo france24
[Música]